ouverture du procès de quad à liestal et
de neuf autres terroristes auteurs
présumés des attentats parisien de 85 et
routes bloquées opération escargot des
chauffeurs routiers qui réclamaient une
baisse du prix du gasoil arrestation de
l'ancien numéro un est allemand erich
honecker accusé de haute trahison son
procès aura lieu en mars
la roumanie divisé après les opposants
au régime les partisans ont défilé à
bucarest
bonsoir il y à des hommes qui posent des
bombes qui tuent et qui n'ont pour
autant aucun remords c'est apparemment
le cas de fouad ali saleh considéré
comme le principal responsable de la
série d'attentats qui avaient endeuillé
la france en 1986 il y avait eu 13 morts
et 250 blessés
le procès de fouad ali saleh et de ses
complices est ouvert aujourd'hui au
tribunal de paris
mais la morgue et l'hystérie du
terroriste pro iranien était telle que
le président a dû expulser ce dessin de
bap illustre bien le climat qui a régné
cet après midi dans la salle et que
clément weill raynal décrit pour le dix9
pertur de l'audience fouad ali saleh
considéré comme le chef du réseau fouad
ali saleh explosé interpelle le
président je ne m'appelle pas fouad ali
saleh je m'appelle mort à l'occident
dieu m'a envoyé pour ranger l'islam
l'occident a tué des millions d'enfants
l'occident sera anéantie je jetterai une
bombe atomique sur l'occident le
président essaye de procéder aux
premiers interrogatoires mais fouad ali
saleh continue c'est l'islam qui veut se
venger ses les opprimés qui veulent tuer
la guerre la guerre la guerre répète
inlassablement fouad ali saleh qui au
bout de cinq minutes est expulsé du
tribunal reste dans le box les neuf
autres membres du réseau
huit hommes et une femme fatima kheraj
les pousses de fouad ali saleh ils
assistent silencieux aux débats sans
donner vraiment l'impression d'y
participer mais pour la défense 12
avocats au total il manque dans ce
procès un personnage essentiel
le mystérieux lofti ben salah la taupe
qui aurait dénoncé le réseau à la dst
lofty est aujourd'hui introuvable pour
la justice du moins selon la défense cet
informateur existe bel et bien
nous aimerions que ce zombie du dossier
demandent un avocat viennent témoigner
devant le tribunal
cela permettrait d'éclairer certaines
zones d'ombré du dossier la procédure et
l'examen des faits occuperont toute
cette semaine
réquisitoire et plaidoiries la semaine
prochaine les débats sont prévus pour
durer 15 jours
pourquoi fouad ali saleh exprime-t-il
une telle violence le fait-il pour des
raisons essentiellement politiques ou
bien son cas relève t-il aussi de la
psychologie ou de la psychanalyse
portrait par jean françois grégoire
il semblait garder un mystère que
personne ne pouvait percée ainsi parle
karima de son mari fouad ali saleh salek
une haine sans borne pousse à insulter
ses juges à les menacer de mort
cette véhémence salines en a pas
toujours usé après son arrestation en
mars 87 à paris il se disait victime
d'un complot de la dst mais neuf mois
plus tard salle explose et se proclame
combattants de la cause islamique
normal pour ce tunisien de 31 ans au
parcours chaotique et un certain
naissance à paris études primaires dans
une institution chrétienne de tunis et
puis très vite l'islam un apprentissage
ou qu'on dit qu'elle fouad ali saleh ne
se montra guère brillant mais si
déterminer qu'on entrevoit pour lui
d'autres débouchés que l'enseignement
coranique
de retour à paris l'étudiant salle et
devient recruteurs dans les librairies
et foyer islamique entre de vente
d'avocats dans les couloirs du métro
nous sommes en 86 x d'ali saleh a
accompli sa mission
la logistique terroriste est prête les
attentats peuvent commencer
les terroristes jugé aujourd'hui n'ont
pas eu un seul regard pour les familles
des victimes et pour les rescapés des
attentats qui ont tenu à être présent
lors de cette première audience
mais il n'est pas sûr qu'ils parviennent
à éviter leur regard tout au long du
procès jean paul girouard ils
attendaient ce moment depuis trois ans
et demi 80 victimes ou parents de
victimes se sont portés parties civiles
une dizaine d'entre eux étaient présents
pour l'ouverture du procès pour
témoigner par leur simple présence et
pour obtenir des réponses à de vieilles
questions septembre
bon d'essayer de comprendre ce qui s'est
passé pourquoi elles ont des victimes
ensuite soit représenté la mémoire des
traits faire comme décédé pendant cette
vague et elles veulent aussi opposé face
au langage des terroristes la présence
des victimes présence digne est
effective pour ne pas être les oubliés
de son procès ce que je recherche à
travers ce procès c'est bien évidemment
la vérité d'essayer de comprendre les
motivations des assassins je pense qu'on
peut difficilement les qualifier
autrement de connaître l'implication de
dégâts aux responsables politiques du
pays que je prends je peux citer parce
que l'effet trop
que c'est l'iran donc essayer de savoir
ce qui s'est passé comment ça a été
organisé de connaître également
du côté français savoir ce que la raison
d'état nous a peut-être caché jusqu'à
aujourd'hui la dépense a d'ores et déjà
demandé que ces victimes soit écarté du
procès les avocats des prévenus estiment
que leur présence est injustifiée en
tribunal correctionnel et qu'elle ne
sera qu on cour d'assises rassemblement
cet après-midi à paris à la mémoire de
malik oussékine tué lors des
manifestations de décembre 86 plusieurs
organisations étudiantes syndicales et
antiracistes ont protesté contre le
verdict de la cour d'assises de paris
qui a reconnu coupable brigadier suite
et garcia et de police y ont été
condamné samedi à cinq ans de prison
avec sursis pour le premier et deux ans
avec sursis pour les chômeurs mais il
reste libre
soyez attentifs et prudents si vous
prenez la route demain dans les bouches
du rhône dans les régions bordelaises et
lilloises mais aussi dans d'autres
régions
renseignez-vous en tout cas avant de
partir les routes pourraient être
bloqués comme elles l'ont été
aujourd'hui par des routiers mécontents
ils font partie de l'une des
organisations de transporteurs et
protestent notamment contre la hausse du
prix du gazole nathalie darrigrand
routes surchargées ou bloquer peu
importe la tactique le résultat
elle-même circulation minimum et
embouteillages monstres et cie en savoie
700 camions ont empêchés et empêchent
encore les automobilistes de passer à
l'opposé le pont de tancarville étaient
déserts interdite d'accès en fait les
bouches du rhône la région lilloise la
basse seine et le bordelais ont été
particulièrement touchés par ce
mouvement des prix sera serré par les
branches les grosses entreprises nos
chargeurs
france qui vont chez no 7 qui nous
imposent de fruits on a tous joué le
maître mot de ce conflit la concurrence
les petits transporteurs demandent de
l'aide
la baisse du prix du gasoil mais surtout
la régularisation des contrats de sous
traitance
en clair une moralisation de leur
relation avec les gros transporteurs
d'où l'absence sur les routes
aujourd'hui de la très puissante
fédération nationale des transporteurs
routiers
les internes et chefs de clinique en
grève n'entendent pas désarmé ils ont
manifesté une nouvelle fois cet après
midi à paris marie-claire tiers les a
suivis il était environ 4000 interne et
chefs de clinique à manifester pour
réclamer
premièrement le libre accès au secteur 2
le secteur qui permet de dépasser les
honoraires fixés par la sécurité sociale
deuxièmement la liberté de choisir leur
lieu d'installation
les manifestants voulaient ainsi faire
pression sur la reprise des négociations
à propos de la convention médicale et à
17 heures ils ont fait irruption dans la
salle de réunion qui l'ont évacué peu
après pour se rendre au ministère de la
santé trois de leurs délégués
participent à ces négociations
après un mois d'impasse les caisses de
sécurité sociale et les syndicats de
médecins ont repris aujourd'hui leurs
marchandages à propos des règles de
remboursement des actes médicaux
l'objectif du gouvernement maîtriser les
dépenses de médecine de ville qui ont
augmenté de 10% ces douze derniers mois
donc limiter le secteur 2 à honoraires
libres
ce que refuse bien sûr les syndicats de
médecins faudra-t-il donc remettre à
plat le système conventionnel à l'est
l'actualité toujours aussi dense en
toile de fond vous le savez le passage
difficile à la démocratie on a le
sentiment d'assister un bras de fer
entre les communistes repenti qui
veulent bien changé mais sans effacer
pour autant la faucille et le marteau et
leurs adversaires qui eux souhaitent
aller jusqu'au bout de la liberté nous
l'avons constaté aujourd'hui encore dans
trois pays l'allemagne de l'est tout
d'abord où cet affrontement s'est
illustré d'une manière spectaculaire
l'ex-dirigeant erich honecker a été
arrêté dès sa sortie d'hôpital il sera
jugé pour haute trahison
hélène risacher dernier acte de la chute
erich honecker ce matin à sa sortie
d'hôpital l'ancien numéro un
du en prison à berlin est erich honecker
sera jugé en mars pour haute trahison 77
ans opéré d'un cancer du rein il ya deux
semaines au necker a dirigé la rda
pendant 17 ans avant d'être renversé en
octobre dernier
aujourd'hui plus de la moitié des
anciens membres du politburo du parti
communiste est-allemand sont en prison
erich honecker risque la réclusion à
perpétuité
son incarcération aujourd'hui peut être
considérée comme un gage du nouveau
gouvernement afin de se démarquer de
l'ancien régime communiste mais le
numéro le premier ministre hans modrow
rejette lice il l'idée simpliste de la
vengeance
il souhaite même que erich honecker soit
gracié et libéré pour raisons de santé
pour hans modrow le combat à mener pour
regagner la confiance perdue apaiser les
critiques contre son gouvernement
ce combat implique la participation de
l'opposition
la nuit dernière après de difficiles
tractations la table ronde entre
l'opposition et les dirigeants
est-allemands a décidé de constituer un
gouvernement de coalition le premier
gouvernement à majorité non communiste
de l'histoire de l'allemagne de l'est
de plus les premières élections libres
de rda ont été avancée au 18 mars au
lieu du 6 mai devant les députés tout à
l'heure le premier ministre hans modrow
a fait le bilan des tensions économiques
et sociales qui menace la rda
pour lui ce nouveau gouvernement d'union
nationale est le seul moyen de
stabiliser le pays jusqu'aux élections
d'ici mercredi chacun des huit
mouvements d'opposition il doit choisir
un représentant qui sera ministre sans
portefeuille en roumanie l'opposition
entre les deux camps se voit carrément
dans la rue manifestations et contre
manifestations se succèdent à un rythme
inquiétant et dix pisteurs ne braderont
pas notre pays nous sommes avec le front
le centre de bucarest aujourd'hui
résonnant des slogans des sympathisants
du front de salut national
depuis la fin de la matinée les cortèges
remontent les rues de bucarest pour
converger vers la place de la victoire
devant le grand bâtiment du ministère
des affaires étrangères au passage
devant les sièges des partis
d'opposition les échanges sont vifs mais
il n'y aura par l'incident place de la
victoire
des milliers peut-être dix mille
manifestants pour la plupart des
ouvriers arrivé là par cars camions
entiers parfois même de province
il y avait ce coût était là lui il n'est
pas venu de paris le nude roi roumain
aujourd'hui n'a pas eu de problème pour
s'exprimer
le front est ouvert au dialogue avec le
peuple tout entier
non le front ne cèdera pas à la pression
car le peuple est avec lui pour les
nouveaux dirigeants roumains la
meilleure preuve en est certainement
cette manifestation une manifestation
pour le moins très bien organisée reste
qu'elles ne peuvent faire oublier les
slogans d'hyères la démocratie par la
pérestroïka le fond des missions pas de
semis communisme cette fois ils étaient
plusieurs dizaines de milliers à les
scandé et à conspuer ironisé ce coup
une autre précision sur la roumanie les
quatre anciens dignitaires du régime de
ceausescu jugeait pour complicité de
génocide ont plaidé coupable aujourd'hui
devant le tribunal militaire de bucarest
tout en se présentant
drôle de défense comme les exécutants de
dictateurs fanatiques les roumains
attache à la démocratie doivent envier
les polonais qui eux vont relativement
vide
le parti communiste polonais est
moribond le mouvement qui lui succède
n'hésite pas à prendre une appellation
que la gauche française répugne à
utiliser
il s'appellera désormais parti
social-démocrate de la république
polonaise mémona hintermann 1402
délégués ont voté pour transformer le
parti communiste parti social démocrate
un nom honni en effet est porteur de
toutes les calamités il n'y a pas si
longtemps
en réalité la méthode caméléon a permis
à la nomenklatura de conserver des hauts
postes
ainsi les cellules du parti ne
disparaîtront pas des usines ce parti
social-démocrate polonaise sera dirigée
par alexander valise qui l'a réformateur
de 36 ans un homme intelligent qui
pourrait bien n'être vitaux l'otage de
la vieille garde
officiellement le parti communiste a
fait son mea culpa oui il a été constaté
louis les responsables de toute cette
pollution qui le symbole même d'une
économie qui a échoué
il sait qu'il doit encore est que 5% des
voix s'il y avait des élections
maintenant
mais le parti social démocrate espère
recueillir 25 % des voix non pas en
avril lors des élections locales
mais est-elle d'après lors des
législatives anticipées des élections
qui pourrait être suivie dit aujourd'hui
d'un scrutin présidentiel
et on voit déjà le social-démocrate
charouz l esprit céder sa place à
valises à va les a pour qui le sabordage
du parti état d'ici il devra en effet
éviter les divisions au sein du
solidarité prénom oscar non la fontaine
il n'est pas français il est tellement
et contemporain allemand de l'ouest
oskar lafontaine et social démocrate il
vient de remporter d'une manière
brillante des élections en sarre et
certains le perçoivent déjà comme le
prochain rival d'helmut kohl portrait
par laurent dresse de notre bureau de
strasbourg politique allemande
il s'agit d'abord d'une montée en force
des sociaux démocrates désormais doté
d'un candidat à la chancellerie crédit
les battant dans la perspective des
élections législatives de décembre pour
les chrétiens-démocrates et pour helmut
kohl en particulier il s'agit d'un
camouflet et cela sur la question même
de la réunification un camouflet infligé
par celui qui dès novembre disait
attention toute spéculation sentimentale
sur cette question est une mauvaise
politique
il s'agit d'un problème économique et
social extrêmement grave et qu'il faut
régler de sang froid pour nous français
enfin cela signifie qu oscar sera
peut-être dès l'an prochain
le partenaire de françois mitterrand
pour traiter des questions allemandes et
européennes et qu'il est donc temps de
s'intéresser de près à cet ex gauchistes
écologistes baroque devenu un
gestionnaire redoutable et surtout
héritiers pour ce qui est de la
politique à l'est des idées du vieux
lyon i liebrandt 76 en plus populaire et
plus fraser de rois que jamais les
autres nouvelles du jour notamment
celles qui se sont produites en france
bien baveux illustre la première de ces
nouvelles c'est à dire le nombre
important d'évasion nouvelle avec hervé
dino
la cavale des quatre évadé de la maison
d'arrêt de loos se poursuit tout comme
la polémique autour de la fiabilité de
nos prisons les syndicats de
surveillants sont montés au créneau cet
après midi il refuse qu'on leur fasse
porter la responsabilité de ces évasions
en chaîne et dénonce la politique menée
par jean-pierre dintilhac
le directeur de l'administration
pénitentiaire
surprise à cannes michel mouillot est
élu dès le premier tour de l'élection
municipale partielle
il recueille 57 % des suffrages
améliorant de 15% le score réalisé lors
de l'élection de mars 89 élections qui
avaient été annulées par le conseil
d'état
le front national qui comptait faire de
cette consultation un second dreux n'a
pu réaliser ses ambitions
n'obtenant que 20 ans et demi pour cent
des suffrages
quinze blessés ce matin dans un
carambolage sur l'autoroute a6 aux
portes de lyon le brouillard extrêmement
dense qui recouvrait la région est à
l'origine de ces accidents en chaîne
dans lesquelles une soixantaine de
véhicules ont été impliqués
le trafic a été rétabli en milieu
d'après midi
de sérieuses perturbations perspectives
sur le réseau ferré pour la première
fois depuis plus de dix ans six des sept
organisations représentatives des
cheminots appellent à la grève le
mouvement qui débute demain à 20 heures
et qui s'achèvera jeudi à 6 heures
devrait affecter l'ensemble des réseaux
grandes lignes et banlieue ainsi que la
ligne c du rer et un autre télégramme il
parvient à l'instant c'est une triste
nouvelle les recherches pour retrouver
le chalutier lafayette disparu depuis
jeudi avec cinq hommes à bord ont été
suspendues
cet après midi c'est ce qu'indique la
marine faute d'élément nouveau dit elle
et en raison de mauvaises conditions
météo
les recherches vient d'être suspendu ski
super géant de val d'isère on attendait
franck piccard ce fut armand filet il
est jeune c'est l'une des deux plus
jeunes skieurs du circuit
il est à l'honneur aujourd'hui avec un
autre suisse un autre jeune skieur rémy
de nietzsche et 3e de la descente le
matin armand schielé réveil le speaker
de la course dans ce super géant de val
d'isère
parti loin après les ténors en 22e
position ce jeune alsacien de 22 ans
trouve la glisse idéal sur une neige
plus rapide qu'en début de course il
signe le deuxième temps de l'épreuve à
trois centièmes seulement du vainqueur
le suisse lauscher picard et 9e les
autres français loin derrière la
performance d'art manche il n en a que
plus de valeur et ce jeune sociétaire de
l'équipe de france réserve retiendra
qu'il a encore laissé aujourd'hui
derrière lui pirmin zurbriggen
wass mayer ou encore le norvégien
skaardal trois petits centièmes de van
schil et autant dire à une longueur de
flocons on retrouve donc le jeune suisse
steve lauscher partie des profondeurs du
classement avec le dossard 46 le cheikh
ne semble pas vraiment réalisé qu'il
vient de signer l'exploit de la journée
décidément en ce super géant de val
d'isère été fait pour les jeunes loups
de la saison 90 ils se sont donné
rendez-vous dès demain dans le super g
des menuires
d'autres images sportives elles viennent
d'outre-atlantique il s'agit de football
de football américain ça n'a rien à voir
avec le football européen africains ou
sud américains personnellement je ne
comprend toujours pas les raids mais
alain d'orgon ces passionnés ils vous
racontent c'est une finale
joe montana le plus talentueux
quarterbacks de tous les temps la pierre
angulaire des fortunes en art de san
francisco est aussi l'homme de tous les
records
sen passe pour sun tzu down sur les huit
inscrits par son équipe élue pour la
troisième fois meilleur joueur du super
bowl le super bowl et au football
américain
ce que la coupe du monde et au football
européen le super bowl est aussi de
paradigme business doublé d'un cyclone
médiatique qui s'est abattue à 17 heures
heure locale
aux etats unis la minute de publicité
parmi les 28 qui ont entrecoupé la
retransmission télévisée est la plus
chère du monde vendue 1 million 500
mille dollars
une mine d'or pour les annonceurs
sachant que le super bowl bénéficie du
plus fort taux d'audience au superdome
de la new orleans la fête sportive a été
totale pour les fortunes à une heure de
san francisco qui sous l'impulsion du
clairvoyant joe montana ont pulvérisé
les broncos de denver 55 avis vainqueur
pour la deuxième fois consécutivement du
super bowl san francisco ce bâti un
palmarès impressionnant bien ce journal
est presque terminée nous avons gardé
quelques minutes c'était délibéré pour
vous parler de la 3 et des programmes de
l'a3 nous le ferons désormais
régulièrement dans le journal dans le
19/20 je crois qu'il faut un
décloisonnement entre les programmes et
l'information est notre invité ce soir
c'est marie odile monchicourt bonsoir
saint-paul-de-la-croix de l'a3
dorénavant puisque ce soir je je vais
pour la première fois apparaître dans
une nouvelle émission c'est une
naissance
l'émission qui s'appelle tensions et qui
fait partie de l'ensemble de la soirée
finalement puisque la soirée commencera
avec un superbe film de louis malle qui
est vie privée et puis après le journal
nous aurons un plateau ces tensions et
sur ce plateau et bien nous aurons des
invités prestigieux puisqu'il y aura
louis malle michel piccoli peter brook
et finira claude carrière en direct en
direct ou indirect
alors tant sur ça s'écrit comment pour
nos téléspectateurs tmp sms ou bien on
joue sur les mots en ou sur les mots et
vous parlerai de quad en tension avec un
plateau aussi prestigieux alors
d'intention nous parlerons de sujets qui
seront en général
extrait du film alors ce soir vie privée
c'est c'est la vie de brigitte bardot
une vie d'enfer une vie de star infernal
d'enfer duthen vraiment danseurs d'enfer
d'adam vie privée on le ressent comme ça
et je vais je pense que que ce devait
être des eaux parce que les stars d'hier
se sont pas les mêmes tard
qu'aujourd'hui et c'est ce dont nous
parlerons aussi ce soir donc vous
parlerai de brigitte bardot avec
brigitte bardot
alors brigitte bardot peut-être parlera
au téléphone elle ne veut pas se montrer
en général non mais on va on va la
regarder jouer dans une interview qui
date de quelques années où elle parle de
sa vie de zinc qui doit dater de 2 27
ans donc une patrick le madré son
réalisateur est moins regardant la vie
ressemble à une grande prison agréable
mais c'est un peu une prison quand même
c'est à dire que vous ne savez pas nous
appartenait plus non j'appartiens à tout
le monde on me fait dire des choses que
je ne dis pas non nécessaire des choses
que je ne sais pas c'est un peu je vous
dis on a un peu l'impression de ne plus
être libre mais elle vous l'avions
téléphone vous le dira ce soir un mois
chez moi je n'ai pas parlé avec brigitte
bardot
mais ce qui apparaît dans le film parce
que le film de louis malle est vraiment
inspiré de la vie brigitte bardot et
elle ne pouvait ne pouvait rien faire
les stars il y a trente ans c'était des
personnes qui étaient portées tellement
ou tellement loin derrière la vie des
gens que finalement elle n'arrivait pas
du tout envie personnelle mais elles
doivent se cacher peut-être pour le
reste et bonne chance marie-odile
monchicourt et je rappelle donc le film
de louis malle à 20h35 20h40 vie privée
avec brigitte bardot ce journal est
terminée vous allez regarder ce soir là
trois avec un programme très alléchant
ma recrutement vous présentera soir 3 à
22h15 et dans quelques secondes
michel tour et vous donnera des
précisions sur le temps qu'il fera
demain bonsoir à demain 19h après la
journée infos sur l'a3 et après le
journal d'anne de coup de neuf au revoir